for me the way that I deal with it is if
I lose a big hand I the first thing that
happens is I start thinking did I do
anything wrong in the hand let me think
about in a sort of deconstructive way in
analytical way what was my play during
the hand what was the other players
responses could I have done something
different should I have done anything
different was anything in my control
that went wrong now that does two things
the first thing is that it shuts that it
kind of shuts down that sort of limbic
system response and gets you into your
frontal lobe which is actually really
important so the frontal lobe is where
we think the limbic system is where we
have our emotions if we let our limbic
system go really light up then that
actually shuts our frontal lobe down so
we're not going to think clearly going
forward so by immediately saying i'm
going to start thinking about this
analytically and i'm going to start
going through the hand you're really
subverting that that sort of emotional
response through almost through
distraction but there's actually sort of
a psychophysiological thing that's going
on but the other thing it does is it
really trains you to look at mistakes as
opportunities which i think is really
important to say there isn't a failure
like i didn't fail in a hand i made a
mistake and that's an opportunity for me
to learn and not make that mistake in
the future and really become a better
poker player because of something I
might have done wrong and sometimes the
conclusion after you've gone through
this is not that you did anything wrong
but things just went wrong like you had
aces and they had fives and they put all
their money in the pot when they were
only going to win eighteen percent of
the time and they happen to win and
those kinds of things you don't have any
control over and I think very good poker
players get very good at saying I'm not
going to get upset about things that I
have no control over I'm going to focus
on the things that I do have control
over because those are the things that
are going to make me a winning player in
the future
you